chances are most moviegoers didn't
expect to get their hearts broken by
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom after all
this is standard popcorn action fair
featuring deadly dinos bad decisions by
the humans and a whole lot of fun but
there was one scene that costs many fans
of the hugely popular adventure series
to choke up and walk away rather
traumatized click away now if you're
still avoiding spoilers or you might be
traumatized yourself no one made me come
here I'll be all right the scene that
seems to have gutted a lot of moviegoers
features Chris Pratt's Owen Bryce Dallas
Howard sclera and justice Smith's
Franklin escaping easily Nublar just
seconds before the islands active
volcano destroys the defunct theme park
while some of the dinosaurs have been
transported from the island by Ken
Wheatley salvage operation our trio of
heroes spot a helpless Brachiosaurus who
has been left behind as the clouds of
smoke billow around and eventually
engulf the moaning animal those who
caught fallen Kingdom and theatres have
since flocked to social media to share
their grief over the scene as one user
put it not to be dramatic but I would
die for that Brachiosaurus in Jurassic
world another fan admitted he was lying
in bed thinking about that Brachiosaurus
long after fallen kingdoms credits
rolled one woman compared her outrage
over the Brachiosaurus demise to the way
some fans felt after seeing Star Wars
the last Jedi and another was left
completely crushed after witnessing the
emotionally distressing sequence and
wrote all I want to do is cry and all I
want is a giant hug right now that scene
had no business ruining my emotional
life I'm scarred last but not least at
least one user reached the bargaining
stage of grief over the scene writing
I'd be less emotional if Chris Pratt's
character was eaten by an Allosaurus
which is then eaten by a Tyrannosaurus
Rex which is then eaten by a Mosasaurus
baked there's still another sequel in
the works oh who knows that could very
well still happen oh yeah kid the
Brachiosaurus has always been among the
friendliest members of the Dino Kingdom
in the series after being introduced in
1993 Jurassic Park just the
kind of a big cannibal so it's
especially heartbreaking to watch this
gentle giant collapse under such
excruciating circumstances and director
Juan Antonio Bayona has admitted to
capitalizing on the nostalgia factor
associated with the species he even
played a sadder version of the Jurassic
Park melody over the scene to represent
what he called the ending of a dream
that started 25 years ago there was a
lot while we dry our eyes and try to
scrub away the image of the
Brachiosaurus that's now burned into our
brain we're left with one hope that the
Jurassic world team doesn't pull a stunt
like this again in the third movie
dinosaurs are people - thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]